the first vegan activists are not giving
up their quest to make us all eat Bland
plant-based gruel they've tipped milk
all over the floor of fortnum and Mason
and selfridges in London they've heard
white paint at the gates of the houses
of Parliament now they've targeted a
high-end Steakhouse in London and the
waitresses did what many have wanted to
do with these protesters for a while
take a look
thank you foreign
well joining me uh now is animal
Rebellion spokesman Nathan McGovern and
celebrity chef Aldo zilli got it right
this time he picked me up but it's Aldo
not older Aldo's a very British
pronunciation in Italian uh good to see
you both uh Nathan start with you
um I I don't like vegans very much I
don't think any of you are very healthy
I'm not surprised by that yeah I think
you all look pretty pasty-faced and
unhealthy to me um but that's your
choice what I don't do is I don't go
running into vegan restaurants and start
screaming abuse at you all and have to
be pulled out by people because you're
ruining everyone's fun why do you do
that to meat eaters
well peers you've started on an absolute
blind today I actually brought a little
game with me for the me Aldo perhaps the
audience to play it so Piers Morgan a
vegan Bingo maybe we could zoom on that
from the camera and you've actually just
ticked off wanna straight away I'll just
go with that with looking at row or a
column already so the thing is
within years
technology like Precision fermentation
you know alt protein is going to produce
the exact same products that you love
right now using a fraction of the land
producing a fraction
mean it's the exact same product no but
I like utme fine you know you're beating
the exact same product in fact the more
the more meat I want to eat that's
absolutely fine it is that's fine
actually it's a bit honestly it's true
the more stuff you do like this right I
think I didn't catch that it's true is
it you've said that about three times I
didn't touch it that you like you meet
yes oh oh thanks I didn't get it the
first three times um how committed to
vegan are you how committed a vegan am I
would you eat do you drink almond milk
oh you've ticked off another one
fantastic you are on an absolutely no
answering questions I don't know I'll
keep that one hidden from you take the
phone you just answer the questions
otherwise it's not much of an interview
I mean you can have your little charge
but do you drink almond milk no do you
eat almonds no you eat avocados
no what do you eat what do you drink I
love seasonal British fruit and veg
right you know I love supporting British
Farmers I love going to a farmer's
market seeing what they have to offer
you know I love eating a plant-based
most science now says that if you don't
have a balanced diet it's actually
unhealthy for you yeah exactly that's
why a plant-based diet a balanced
plant-based diet is healthy I'll do what
we what do you feel I mean your
restaurant is very close to where this
happened right what do you feel about
these activists running in ruining
people's meals
listen
um 25 years ago I opened one of the
first vegetarian restaurants in London
it's Soho and if it was now it's
probably more successful today and it
didn't get very successful but anyway
come Carlos was very short
I don't have any problems I've ridden a
vegetarian book not a vegan book
I don't have any problems with vegan and
veganism and vegetarian people because I
have restaurants I'm a consultant for a
number of restaurants number of
restaurant companies and we have vegan
and vegetarians on menus so I don't
understand
when it gets out of hand
that these people have to well they
disrupt our business because they have
no respect for meat eaters uh but if we
were doing the same thing to them they'd
all go nuts right wouldn't you you'll go
nuts if I came running into your little
vegan hell holes and began screaming
abuse you'd all throw your toys out the
brown as you do on a daily basis
I'm gonna throw my toys out the pram
right now peers I'm loving this to be
honest what are you loving I'm loving
that this open conversation that we're
having about this actual quote but why'd
you have to go and and do a restaurant
and disrupt our business disrupt the
customers other people that want to eat
the meat are the people that want to
enjoy themselves they want to go out and
have a night out uh I don't have any
problems you guys come into our
restaurants and ordering a vegan dish in
fact in January we always do a vegan
worry and we got through a lot of
different
ingredients to create menus for you guys
I don't understand why we have to suffer
your mentality of coming to our
restaurants and trying to disrupt the
customers that are having a fantastic
time and they want to eat the steak
what's the answer no it's actually a
good question and actually it's
fantastic that you create fantastic
vegan dishes the fact of the matter is
when we look at high-end restaurants you
know salt-based restaurant Manor up in
Manchester that was also disrupted the
weekend these are symbols of a broken
system you know because he makes nice
symbols of a broken system where you
know there's 1500 quid yeah why is he
making millions around the world I was
in one of his restaurants last week in
Qatar I loved it fantastic but he served
me they're always waiting for you to
show up so I was wondering how long it
would take it's me doing his little uh
salt trick he talked you were you
weren't very good at it even actually
chunked it in front of me he fed me
actually directly fed me the meat into
my mouth it was delicious loved it
if you'd run in and tried to interrupt
and just ruin everyone's night I would
have done what those waitresses did just
thrown you out that's absolutely fine so
what's the point of view what does it
achieve none of you make me want to
change my mind I just think what
annoying little squids honestly I do
it's the same when you're chucking paint
at Van Gogh paintings it's the same when
you're tying yourself to fuel pumps or
hanging yourself on Bridges and stopping
people using Dart for tunnel it's all
the same you're just all too annoying so
the British public don't like annoying
people and they don't like their lives
being disrupted they want their freedom
to have a choice the choices I had in
Qatar last week to have sold by whose
restaurant you made you to do this to my
mouth can you imagine someone coming in
your evening have you got the clip
no but can you imagine you coming to our
restaurants and and then you get some
people coming to your table and trying
to disrupt your evening it's a it's
abuse I'm gonna start Ryan I'm going to
start running into vegan restaurants
and so you can't eat your gruel and just
see how you look like it I'm gonna go to
your house and Shop paintball over it
yes
you've got a right to price oh you've
got me another one big enough
where's the salt where's where's it I
don't need any of this gruel yeah to one
side but I will have a bit of steak just
to you didn't salt it though you see all
you've achieved is you've made me want
to do this just absolutely absolutely
fine
you go for it
[Music]
do you know do you know how many steaks
he's had from my restaurant yeah a lot a
lot a lot but here's my point
I love eating steak I'm not going to
stop eating steak Yeah and the the very
last thing on Earth that will stop
eating steak is people like you with
your pasty faces running into our
restaurants telling us to stop eating
steak that's the very last thing to do
absolutely because you don't represent
to me Vitality or good health you just
want to let you want a good bit of steak
that's absolutely fine you're fully
entitled to that opinion and as I've
just said earlier you're right to
protest if you want to run it your mates
are also the extinction Rebellion right
my mates you're all like interwoven like
you said before we came on like a like a
wool and blanket are you connected or
not no no so we're a sister movement
assistant what's that sounds a bit sexy
we have you know Common goals you know
irritating people
such as tackling the climate and
ecological emergencies which you know
I'm sure all of us what did you think of
Megan and Harry using a private plane
there we go Meghan Markle that's another
one four for nine ah I'm not going to
give you that what did you think of them
using a private plane to go to this uh
award show
you must be furious it's incredible how
you manage are you feeling to turn this
into oh let's dump on Megan your agenda
appears
I just wonder whether you're not in
their plane I just wonder whether do you
feel do you feel angry they used a
private plane or not
what we should have is Affordable Travel
for everyone but they they used what we
should have is Travel Systems do you
criticize something private players you
know or because they're the working
company
I would have much preferred you know why
you can't don't you know then because
this again
you don't want to read a headline
tomorrow saying Nathan McGovern from
animal Rebellion slams Megan and Harry
for using private plane you don't want
to say it because like them you're a
flaming hypocrite you'd rather go in
there we go you've got me a column
you'd rather go into restaurants like
Aldos or salt Bays or whatever and just
make a nuisance of themselves because
you it's easier but what you should be
doing for intellectually honest and say
Megan and Harry stop using private plans
but you won't yeah because they'll say
it right now I will say it right now
final words you about a balanced diet
most science I've read lately says that
actually having no meat in your data
tool is not necessarily A beneficial
official for that matter right or fish
yeah I mean we have to have a balanced
diet and we it's important for our
well-being for getting healthy if you
work out in the gym like I do I need to
have maybe some good protein yeah and if
I if I don't I I did go vegan for six
months
um a couple of years ago
I went vegan for an hour adolescence it
didn't kill me it didn't give up what
about that vegan Greg sausage roll it
was disgusting complete exactly more
calories in a Greg's vegan sausage roll
than there are in a McDonald's
cheeseburgers
at least it tastes better it's naming
the dishes and you know the like the
if you want to win an argument you just
can't be annoying all the time you can't
just ruin everyone's fun and their lives
walking around like you have the only
way forward for the life in the universe
the Nathan McGovern rule book it's not
me Thou shalt do this this and this
unless the American and Harry then you
can do that University it's the ipcc
this isn't me I'm not a scientist right
I'm perfect I think we'll leave it
people from the University
of Harvard you're not an agency neither
of you and you should listen to you're
not an expert I think we'll leave it at
that Nathan
sorry we didn't get them all together
insects yeah
um good to see you both thank you Alder
great to see you great to see you Nathan